hi there this is steve kaufman here
again um
thank you very much for the uh positive
response to the series of videos that i
did on uh
on the seven secrets of language
learning and uh it's kind of got me
fired up plus uh imovies is working for
me now so um i want to do another video
first of all
i am going to do this series
of uh seven secrets in different
languages uh at least i'm gonna try
but before i get into that i just wanted
to have a little discussion here and i'm
looking for feedback
um on this whole issue of of how
languages are taught
and what seem to be the goals of
teachers and learners in a traditional
language learning setting and i must
admit that i haven't really thought this
all through but i just like to ramble
and discuss and i just wish we were all
able to sit down over a table and
face to face and exchange views and so
forth but we can't so i'll present my
views and i look forward to hearing your
views
um i had a uh
online sort of discussion uh which
became a podcast
where i spoke to a teacher whose name is
sean and i put it up on my blog and he's
a teacher of spanish and i think english
and of course he
explained to me how he uses different
reading strategies
asking students to identify cognates uh
asking students to
explain their strategies and working
their way through difficult texts in
spanish
uh he does let them
tackle uh you know a sports page or
whatever
so that was kind of interesting i'm not
a big fan of reading strategies i'm
never interested in
cognates i don't like the word people
don't even know what it means
most people are going to identify that
there are
words and say spanish which are similar
to words in english uh that's part of
the discovery that in a way we should
leave to the student that really needn't
be pointed out but that was not the main
issue the main thing that i felt in
listening to sean my impressions were
first of all
that he's obviously a very conscientious
teacher
and wants the best for his students
uh he told me how he has them
write or develop a story with the words
that they have
learned and that after
however many months with him they are
comfortable doing that and they really
know the uh the words that they have
learned and how many words is that i
said he said a hundred words
and so i started thinking like why would
anyone want to speak when they only have
a hundred words
what is the practical application of
that
uh i've been learning korean now for a
while and i have some four thousand
words
and uh i went into a korean restaurant
here in vancouver and i was surrounded
by korean people
uh speaking korean a mile a minute and i
could not i mean i caught the odd word
here and there but i have no idea what
they were talking about
uh i can engage someone in a very simple
korean conversation and as long as they
stay at my level
uh like the weather is nice
i'm learning korean things of that
nature then i'm okay
so from my point of view i'm nowhere in
korea i consider my my uh i am not in a
position to engage anyone in korea
uh i am interested in in acquiring more
more words and phrases so that i can
first of all understand korean that i
can understand better
the content that we have at link
and so i thought more about this night
and i think that in school
uh given that most students are not that
interested in learning languages
and as sean explained they need some
specific
achievements tasks
because they're not intrinsically
motivated so he gives them a task
find the cognates or identify the
infinitives in this text
text so they've got a specific task and
they do the task and
maybe they get marked on it or they
think they've done something
in terms of learning the language
um identifying the infinitives i don't
think it does much and then that result
is at the end of a lot of this
school learning of languages first of
all as sean pointed out the
three-quarters of them drop out so in
the end they don't end up being able to
do anything in spanish but even those
that stay in it based on what i've heard
they don't end up being able to do much
with their language so what are we
really achieving and certainly we have
numbers in canada where english-speaking
kids in the french school system
uh don't end up speaking french
i think you know where i'm coming on all
of this is that um
the main task is to acquire words as
i've said many times
and to familiarize yourself with the
language by listening to a lot of the
language and reading the language so
i mean here's here's an idea if i were
teaching and i and i accept that i'm not
a classroom teacher and everyone's going
to say that what you're saying is
totally unrealistic
blah blah blah
but maybe it's good to look at some of
these
activities like classroom activities
from my perspective which is not that of
a classroom teacher because the
classroom teachers
all get together and talk about what
they should do and and the net result is
not very effective
so maybe we need somebody from the
outside to look in and make some
suggestions
and one of the regular criticisms that i
hear is that the kids won't read if
they're just told to read that they find
this boring and so forth but i also put
on my blog the linguist on language
i put a report in the globe and mail
paper here in canada about how
in the united states there was this
person who
came up with a revolutionary idea that
kids should be allowed to choose what
they want to read and the net result was
an overwhelming response from the kids
who really started reading and they
began by reading perhaps
less
you know exalted works of literature but
they eventually ended up reading quite a
lot of different kinds of books
and so that there's a number and i
mentioned the previous example in new
brunswick there are a number of examples
from
uh you know uh
different situations in classrooms where
kids if allowed to read in fact do read
so i don't know some people do some
people don't i guess but what i would
propose is that that in a language
classroom and we should start them as
early as possible there should be only
two goals for these kids
one
is to
again i'm using link as an example so
that if they had access to a link type
of system
through their little portable whatever
or on their computer or in some way or
maybe even going
through it in the classroom
that they have to save as many words as
possible like every week they have to
save if it were linked they'd have to
create 100 links so they can only do
that if they're going through some text
so they have to read so it becomes a
measurement of their activity and the
second goal is to arrive at
as large a possible
uh number
as large as possible a number of known
words again
passive knowledge understanding first
and foremost this pressure for active
vocabularies is to my mind is misplaced
uh so that we would measure their
activity and we would measure the known
words the way we do at link and at the
end of the year they would get a closed
test which is this text with some words
left blank and a drop down list of five
words and have to choose the right word
and so that on and this is going to
easily be done electronically so that on
all the words that they claim to have
learned that they claim to know
uh they would be tested and they would
have to have a very high pass fail
on this closed test in order to say yes
you have completed the work you have
maintained your level your activity
level by saving so many words and
through all of your reading now we
identify that at least passively you
know these words and you proved it in
your closed test and that's all that's
all there are tasks
now in addition to that in the classroom
uh kids should be allowed to watch
movies read books listen to stories
talk if they want to but not talk if
they don't want to my whole point is
that the speaking or talking
is overdone it's not so important
because
for most people who study the language
uh their opportunity to speak it is very
limited
uh therefore if the focus is on
understanding and
and
increasing the vocabulary these are
meaningful goals within the context of
how they're going to use the language
and if they build up this vocabulary and
if they build up their ability to
understand
when they are put in a situation where
they need to speak the speaking will
come along very very quickly because
ultimately in order to speak well
ultimately you have to speak a lot
and if you are not in a position where
you have to speak a lot then it becomes
quite unrealistic
to make speaking such an important part
of the language learning process
uh such as sean
who has his kids uh speaking or writing
a story
when they have a hundred words
which i think is a waste of time
uh and that the proof is that
in our existing language uh teaching
system
where we emphasize producing the
language and producing it correctly
very very very very few kids end up
speaking the language if on the other
hand the focus was entirely
on increasing one's ability to
understand
increasing vocabulary year after year
listening to more stuff watching tv
programs listening to music give them
spanish pop music whatever it might be
just as in sweden where they're very
successful at learning english most the
kids learn by listening to popular music
and watching tv
so give them that kind of exposure
passive exposure they're going to start
speaking on their own at some point but
don't try to get them to speak when they
have 100 words i i think that's just a
meaningless exercise so what i would
like some feedback on here
is the idea that the entire emphasis in
language instruction
should be on comprehension
and vocabulary and that the speaking
will come later
when
uh
circumstances permit when there's an
opportunity to speak when the
learner wants to speak but it should not
be something that started in other words
speaking instruction and getting
kids to speak in class or students to
speak in any language class should just
not be a part of what is taught and it
has the added advantage that if i'm in a
classroom i don't have to listen to
other people read poorly and speak
poorly which probably doesn't do my
language learning very much good so
perhaps a bit extreme
every language class
in the school should be based on link
measuring the activity index and the
known words which are easily controlled
on the system so i'm sure that
my uh
like and dislike numbers on youtube here
will uh will reflect a strong opposition
to these ideas and i look forward to
hearing from you thank you for listening